Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Fühle mich jetzt auch schon viel besser an die Nuss.
Das ist schön. Dein Akzent ist auch wieder normal.
Buch, Netzpolitik, die äh ja ähm.
Hundertdreiunddreißigste.
Hundertdreiunddreißigste Folge, so sieht es aus und ähm da sind wir wieder.
Linus. Ja, es hallt hier noch ein bisschen. Ich äh habe ja noch nicht die Akustik so im Griff, wie ich das äh gerne hätte.
Hast du hast du dein Haus noch nicht vermeter ebnet.
Nee, aber das äh findet bald statt. Ich glaube schon, ich ich habe schon einen Plan.
Okay, wunderbar. Da wird sich der Vermieter freuen, wenn du da erst mal deinen ganzen Kram an die Wand geleimt hast.
Genau, ohne Basotek ist ja nicht, ne?
Nee, diesmal klingt das besser.
Was macht man denn vielleicht ganz kurz, ähm was mache ich denn, wenn die, wenn die Bude halt? Möbel reinstellen, Teppich äh äh.
Alles, alles, was den, was den Schall bricht, ist äh hilfreich und äh den Schall brechen halt Bücherbände, wunderbar. Alles, was so
uneben ist, nicht glatt, also problematisch sind glatte Wände, Fenster, alles, was irgendwie glatt ist.
Gastische. Und ähm Teppich hilft, Vorhänge helfen. Sind allerdings,
nicht so absorbierend, wie man's vielleicht ähm vermuten möchte. Und äh es gibt natürlich dann so verschiedene Schaumstoffe,
und ähm dieser Basottext ist halt der mit Abstand teuerste, aber halt auch mit Abstand der der Beste. Das ist halt auch das Zeug.
Mit Abstand der einzige, den du kaufst.
Ja, ich kaufe halt immer nur das Beste.
So bin ich.
Der Tim.
Ja, na ja, ist halt auch irgendwie gleich B eins, hat keine Brandlast und so. Das ist so das Zeug, was auch so in äh Motorhauben und so weiter äh landet, ne, zur
Reduktion, also das ist halt so ein Universalstoff, der einfach sowohl den Brandanforderungen genügt, als auch farblich bleibt, als auch formstabil ist, als auch,
extremen Sound schluckt. So ein ein Wundermittel der chemischen Industrie.
Wie ist immer der, wie ist dieser die alte Weisheit? Äh billig kann ich mir nicht leisten, weil wer billig kauft, kauft zweimal oder sowas in.
Ja, so sieht's nämlich aus. Da, glaube ich, fest dran. Außerdem teuer äh teuer gekauft, das kriegt man meistens auch noch teuer verkauft.
Kannst du eigentlich nur wegschmeißen.
Es stimmt, es stimmt, ich ich hätte wir müssen zu Themen kommen, wo ich dir widersprechen kann oder wo ich.
Wo ich mehr weiß. Äh SIM-Karten zum Beispiel.
Ein bisschen weiß ich ja auch was.
Mal gucken wie viel.
Du hast auf jeden, nee, also wenn ich unser Repertoire mit mit rein, dann hast du nicht mehr als ich, aber in in aktiver Nutzung hast du auf jeden Fall mehr als ich
Ich wollte eigentlich nur noch zur letzten Woche kurz einen einen Nachtrag machen. Wir hatten ja lange über die Angriffe, die über das die durch die Kenntnis des KI äh möglich sind, gesprochen.
Du erinnerst dich. Und ähm dann äh ist mir nachher noch so eingefallen, dass es ja noch andere Keys auf der SIM-Karte gibt, die zu haben ähnlich interessant ist,
Und äh zwar sind das die Unterschlüsse. Da hatte ich,
auch schon mal was erklärt, vor allem in der Sendung mit dem Ulf Buhrmeier, das müsste irgendwie Lokbuch Netzpolitik hundert sonst was gewesen sein.
Wie heißt der Schlüssel? Rothaar.
Uta. Also oder ich weiß nicht, ob die Keys wirklich die heißen, das sind eigentlich Keysets, die auf Tars sitzen und die SIM-Karte hat viele Tars und,
so eine zweistellige Anzahl Kiesets
aber oder bis zu eine zweistellige, aber der entscheidende Punkt ist, dass OTA steht für Over VR. Nämlich ähm Konfigurations-Updates oder äh Java-Applets, die du auf die SIM-Karte äh schicken kannst
Und auch da kommt so eine symmetrische Krypto zum Einsatz und wenn du diesen, also quasi ein äh Verschlüsselungs und Signaturkey, der auf,
Server und Seite in dem Fall die SIM-Karte gleich ist. Und ähm damit kannst du quasi ähm kleinere Java-Applikationen auf die SIM-Karte laden. Ähm,
und der Luca und Luca Melette, Carsten Nohl haben das beim.
Dreißig C3 präsentiert ähm eine SIM-Karten-Mywed, die so folgendermaßen funktionierte. Die schickte einfach alle äh alle Endzeitabstände.
Eine ähm SMS mit den Geokoordinaten an die Zielrufnummer, ja? Und.
Solche Scherze kann's halt mit Simone machen, auch noch ganz andere Sachen, wie zum Beispiel den KI Clown oder so, aber das braucht die NSA ja nicht zu machen. Und in diesem Snowden League findet sich so ein kleiner Hinweis, ah, wir können übrigens Billing Records löschen,
Ähm und das ist natürlich spannend, weil das heißt, du kannst ähm.
Du kannst quasi, wenn du die NSA bist, eine Myware auf einer SIM-Karte installieren, diese Malware zum Beispiel ähm an eine kostenlose Nummer, die ganze Zeit SMS schicken lassen,
Und da du ja äh.
Ähm wie der Frank das so schön im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss nannte, äh dank einer strategischen Deregulierungspolitik,
äh dafür gesorgt hast, dass die dass die meisten Mobilfunknetze ihr Billing ähm outgesourct haben zu deinen Dienstleistern,
kannst du dann äh Einträge von der Rechnung löschen. Das äh ist übrigens was, was ähm auch im Rahmen des natürlich teilweise notwendig wird
wenn die dafür sorgen, dass halt immer so zweite Verbindungen sind. Du erinnerst dich an den Fall, dass wir vor ein paar Jahren, dass da irgendwie einer plötzlich die ganze Zeit Verbindungen nach Pullach auf der Rechnung hatte,
mal, wenn er einen Anruf gemacht hat und das war halt eine eine TKÜ äh Schaltung, wo die vergessen hatten, ihm diese ganzen Verbindungen wieder aus dem Einzelverbindungsnachweis.
Wie viele, wie.
Lange, lange her, der.
Viele Dienstleister gibt es denn da, äh die für die großen Provider diese Tätigkeit übernehmen, diese belegen?
Und genau das habe ich ähm habe ich nicht habe ich nie wirklich recherchiert, da bin ich aber öfter von Journalisten drauf angesprochen worden,
Da gibt's irgendwie ein Paar. Es gibt auch einen israelischen ähm.
Die sagen also, dass das, ich meine, du kannst dir natürlich vorstellen, Billing in so einem Telko,
Invironment ist echt krass. Du hast Millionen von Kunden, die Millionen mit Millionen von anderen Kunden telefonieren, das jeweils zu anderen Tarifen machen, wo der eine sagt halt, okay, die erste Minute wird vollbezahlt, bei dem anderen Kunden wird das so, der andere hat eine Flatrate,
Das sind relativ komplexes Ding, wofür du halt irgendwie auch Computer und so weiter brauchst.
Und äh das äh ist natürlich ganz gerne mal outgesourct und wenn die NSA sagt, lieber Dienstleister, der das outsourct, wir wissen, das ist ein teures Geschäft, aber wir haben Interesse, dass du dieses Chef
Geschäft betreibst, unterbiete doch mal alle anderen, wir machen das dann trotzdem noch lukrativ für dich. So wäre ja jetzt die gängige Verschwörungstheorie. Ähm
dann kommst du eben zu solchen Punkten, dass du sagen kannst, ach so und äh Verbindung zu unseren Nummern werden übrigens grundsätzlich nicht ausgewiesen. Und dann macht halt so Sim, Myware äh Sinn. Weil wir die früher vorher die Angriffsszenarien, die wir ausgemalt haben, waren immer nur
dass du halt die SIM-Karte premium SMS schicken lässt.
Und dadurch äh dann irgendwie monetären Gewinn machst, weil wir eben nicht wirklich wussten, ähm wie man denn so billigen Records löschen könnte, ne? Und
Das ist halt nicht unser Forschungsgebiet.
Ja, das ist definitiv das Forschungsgebiet der NFA und anderer äh Unternehmen in dem Bereich, die dann sehr wohl eben einfach durch Hacking-Maßnahmen sich oder eben auch durch andere Deals äh dieser billigen Rekords dann entledigen.
Aber alles ja äh alles ohnehin egal, weil hat ja jetzt ähm bekannt gegeben, ähm sie wurden ja gar nicht gehackt.
Beziehungsweise schon gehackt, aber sie sagen.
Also hat gesagt, ja, die haben ja nur unsere Office-Netze gehackt und das ist ja in unserem, unserem Security-Perimeter der äußerste, ja, also da gibt's ja noch viel, viel kritischere Sachen. Da haben die sich ja gar nicht reingehackt. Ja, was sie natürlich vergessen ist, dass aus ihren Office-Netzen in diesen Office-Netzen natürlich auch die Administratoren hängen, die dann weiter gehackt
wurden, ne? Das also, das waren
schlechte, schlechtes Tennis, was äh da probiert hat und das Tennis wurde noch schlechter, weil sie nämlich sagten, durch den Diebstahl, der,
der wären drei G und LTE-Karten nicht verwundbar.
Und ähm das stimmt nicht. Ähm und der die Telekom sagte dann so, ja äh wir haben ja sowieso eine,
proritäre Schiffe verwendet und dies auch nicht abhörbar das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen.
Standardverschlüsselungsmechanismus benutzen.
Es gibt äh genau besser werden sie, besser werden sie dran, wenn sie den den Standard äh Mechanismus benutzen würden. Aber du kannst natürlich, du kannst tatsächlich so ein bisschen an diesen Algorithmen rumtricksen, die dann den KC bauen oder sowas. Ähm,
in der Regel ist das aber natürlich nicht klug. Hm, das zu tun,
Weil ähm Standard gibt's schon nicht ohne Grund und das einzige, was die Telekom, also die Telekom sagt, bei uns,
hat der Angriff so nicht sofort zum vollen Erfolg gefühlt, weil gefühlt weil wir noch so einen kleinen Strohhalm des Security nochmal hinten dranhängen haben.
Aber was war denn jetzt ihre Argumentation, warum jetzt ausgerechnet drei G und LTE-Karten nicht verwundbar gewesen sind.
3G und LTE ähm die die ähm,
die Generierung des KC aus dem KI, also die Session Verschlüsselung aus dem Hauptschlüssel äh ein bisschen komplexer ist, aber es ist, es ist stimmt einfach nicht, dass du ähm,
dass du das nicht bräuchtest. So, also das es stimmt, es ist einfach nur schwieriger und ein anderes, ein anderes, du musst was anderes implementieren, als bei 3G,
aber es ist trotzdem äh genauso möglich. Ähm interessanterweise, Entschuldigung, dass ich da immer wieder drauf verweisen muss,
auch dreißig C3 gewesen sein als Karsten und Luca in dem gleichen Vortrag, dass eben auch demonstriert haben. Und äh da hat allerdings andersrum, nämlich da haben sie ein KI gestohlen.
Und dann auf Basis des mit diesem Telefon Telefonat durchgeführt, ja?
Das ist das ist am Ende genau das gleiche, ne? Also ob du ein Telefonat durchführen kannst, das heißt die komplette Authentifizierung und Verschlüsselung selber durchführen kannst oder ob du mit mit sniffen kannst, ist ist in dem Fall das Gleiche.
Naja, also spielt da äh keine Ahnung. Ich habe da, ich habe mir das ungefähr so vorgestellt. Die Leute haben bei der NSA angerufen,
Haben gesagt hallo, ähm Jungs, sag mal, wenn wir jetzt sagen, ihr seid gar nicht bei uns eingebrochen, ne? Würdet ihr dann öffentlich widersprechen,
Sagt die NSA, nein, natürlich nicht, wir wir behaupten immer überall nirgendwo reingebrochen zu sein und da hat Jemato gesagt,
Okay, tschö! Und hat ihre Pressemitteilung veröffentlicht. Also so so scheint mir das da gelaufen zu sein. Ähm.
Aber sie hatten wirklich auch überhaupt keine Ahnung, ne. Also es ist so.
Ja, genau, also es ist halt supergeil, ne. Die die merken das über Jad über Jahre nicht und können dann innerhalb von fünf Tagen sagen, nö, nö, gar nicht.
Also das ist ne so so das äh da müssen wir da müssen mal ein paar Leute rein, die die äh müssen mal ein paar Berater rein. Ähm,
Egal, wir sind ja noch nur in der Nachlese zur letzten Sendung. Microsofts äh dieser Virenscanner, den Microsoft eingebaut hat. Äh wie heißt der denn überhaupt Defender oder so, keine Ahnung. Der Standard Microsoft, der bei
bei ähm der bei bei Windows mit.
Ausgeliefert wird, der entfernt jetzt den Superfisch. Diese. Ähm das fand ich auch sehr.
Sehr amüsant. Ich meine, wenn Microsofts wenn Microsofts Virenscanner dein Produkt als als schadhaft entfernt, dann hast du wirklich ins Klo gegriffen,
Der irgendwo gab's aber auch die Meldung, dass die dass dieser CTO von Lenovo wirklich sich persönlich für diesen Bockmist äh entschuldigt hat, dass ähm.
Das muss er auch.
Das muss er auch und äh das ist äh ist jetzt die Frage, ob man es ihm verzeiht oder nicht. Vielleicht kann man auch sagen, das war einfach mal ähm witzig,
ja? Witzig
und wenn vielleicht sagt man einfach witzig und weiter geht's oder man sagt seid ihr beknackt. Also das muss jeder für sich entscheiden. Ich habe ein Lenovo Laptop gekauft. Fand ich gut. Aber ohne super Fisch.
Sicher?
In den in den USA gibt's gute Nachrichten. Aus den USA gibt's gute Nachrichten. Ja, kein Scheiß.
Man mag's nicht glauben.
Ähm und zwar hat die äh FCC jetzt den ähm die Netzneutralität geregelt.
Wir erinnern uns an die Vorgeschichte. Es
Es gab eine Netzneutralitätsregulation der FCC, es gab dann eine Klage dagegen, dass die FCC keine Grundlage hätte. Dann hat die FC das Internet irgendwie als Universaldienst äh ähm definiert und jetzt wieder neu reguliert.
Und die Netznetralitätsregelungen der FCC besagen ähm oder untersagen es, legale Inhalte, Anwendungen oder Dienste zu blockieren oder auszubremsen.
Ähm.
Es gibt halt noch dieses legal da drin, damit wollen sie sich natürlich das ihre DMCA-Sache offen halten. Äh das heißt, sie wollen ähm Domains äh sperren dürfen. Die äh,
Urheberrechtsverletzen oder oder äh oder Terror über uns bringen und ähm,
sie wollen sie verbieten es also diese Einschränkungen, ich meine, die wirst du bei keiner Regulation wirklich rauskriegen, dass man sagt, okay
auch illegale Inhalte dürfen nicht blockiert werden. Das wäre zwar sehr schön, aber ähm ja passieren wird's nicht. Ähm.
Also Raubkopien gibt's auch weiterhin, aber langsamer.
Langsamer oder halt nur durch irgendwelche Anonymisierungs- und.
Dieses Musikvideo wird hier leider nur in halber Geschwindigkeit präsentiert.
Genau. Dann äh verbietet die FC äh Mautstellen auf der Datenautobahn.
Das haben sie nicht genau so formuliert, oder?
Naja, aber wir wir haben ja diese, wir haben ja jetzt nur mal diese Analogien, da geht's also, wo man sagt, wo man sagt, Internetverkehr geht gegen Entgelt auf eine Schnellspur, ja? Das ist im Prinzip,
Wenn man sich das überlegt, ja nur der, das umgekehrte von von Ich Drossel anderes, ja, wenn ich etwas an, wenn ich wenn ich,
Verbindung A auf die Schnellspur begebe, dann heißt das, ähm Verbindung B wird dadurch gebremst, weil.
Das Kabel wird ja nicht dicker. Die Verbindung wird hier nicht besser. Das aber das heißt, da sagen sie also auch.
Gegen Entgelt etwas schneller zu befördern, ähm ist auch verboten. Ähm.
Allerdings sagen sie natürlich angemessenes Netzwerkmanagement zur L Optimierung des Durchsatzes ist erlaubt, also dieses dieses klassische Argument
Na ja, warum soll deine E-Mail das HD Video des Nachbarn langsamer machen, was auf vielen Ebenen totaler Unsinn ist. Ähm.
Wird damit natürlich also wird damit dem wird damit Rechnung getragen, weil,
Sie sagen, natürlich musst du zu bestimmten Zeiten, sage ich mal, zeitlich unkritischen Traffic vielleicht depriorisieren, um zeitlich kritischen Traffics ähm,
in der Dienstgüter anzubieten, die dein Kunde haben möchte, sagen sie ist völlig in Ordnung. Du darfst das aber nicht tun, dieses Netzwerkmanagement, um dein Geschäft äh zu optimieren. Also Durchsatzoptimierung gerne, aber nicht Geschäftsoptimierung.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du eine,
unbegrenzte Flatrate anbietest und dann irgendwann drosselst, dann ist das eine ein Netzwerkmanagement zur Optimierung deines Geschäfts und nicht eine eine Optimierung,
ein Netzwerkmanagement zur Optimierung des Durchsatzes, ja?
Also kurz gesagt hat, da du darfst äh durchaus quasi äh auf Routingebene hin und her optimieren und solche Feineinstellungen machen, aber es darf dann die meisten eine Rechnung für gestellt werden an irgendjemanden, weil irgendwas so und so gemacht wurde.
Genau. Und diese äh ja prinzipiell genauso. Also wenn du sagst, wir müssen die Videos besser zu unseren Kunden bringen, ist völlig in Ordnung, aber dann muss das eben so machen,
und dass das für alle Videos gilt und nicht nur für die von deiner Streaming-Farm. Ähm
und dann noch der äh dann haben sie noch für die größeren Provider äh Transparenzverordnung, dass sie ja sagen, sie müssen über
anfängliche Werbepreise, Gebühren, Aufschläge und Bandbreitenbegrenzungen Auskunft geben und sie müssen
den Verlust von Datenpaketen bekannt geben, weil äh wie wir wissen, in IP die Leistungsfähigkeit des Netzes daran mess- und vergleichbar wird, äh wie viele Datenpakete du verlierst.
Ähm das ist also in meinen Augen eine sehr gute Netzneutralitätsregulation ähm angemerkt sei, was sie nicht getan haben,
Das ist das Vorschreiben von Tarifen, wäre ja auch eine Möglichkeit gewesen, dass man sagt, dein Tarif darf nicht so, so teuer sein.
Oder du musst einen Tarif zu dem und dem äh,
zu der und der Güte und und Preis anbieten. Ähm sie haben auch nicht reguliert die Pflicht Zugang zur letzten Meile zu geben und das heißt, diese sie,
Das heißt im Prinzip, sie erlauben es dafür, den Netzbetreibern
ihre Monopole zu behalten. Wenn du sagst, ich wir schreiben dir nicht vor, was du nimmst und wir schreiben dir nicht vor, dass du die Infrastruktur diese letzte Meile mit irgendjemandem teilst, während.
Natürlich die meisten ähm Kunden in den USA nur eine Möglichkeit haben, Internet zu bekommen.
Dann ähm heißt das, du darfst dafür dein Monopol behalten.
Also mit anderen Worten, das würde ich mal so als die comcast-Regelung bezeichnen,
betrifft nicht nur in anderen Gebieten sind es andere Betreiber, aber Kongress ist ja besonders bekannt äh dafür in den USA,
nur schlechte Dienstleistungen zu bieten, sondern eben auch an vielen Stellen der einzige Anbieter zu sein, über Kabel und dort auch sehr viel Eingriffe,
äh ins Netz vorzunehmen, uns mit vornehmen zu wollen. Heißt das eigentlich damit, dass dass jetzt dieser Deal, den comcast mit ähm.
Netflix geschlossen hat, hinfällig ist.
Ähm jetzt musst du mir kurz auf die Sprünge.
Das hatten wir, glaube ich, vor so einem halben Jahr. Es gibt nämlich so einen Durchleitungsdeal von Netflix, wo.
Ach so wohl, ja.
Geeinigt haben und wenn ich das jetzt mal so richtig lese, müsste ja das eigentlich, damit dann auch illegal sein, ne, nicht zu lässig oder wie auch immer.
Würde ich jetzt spontan so verstehen. Ähm.
Mal ganz interessant sein zu sehen, was ich aus dieser Regelung jetzt äh ergibt, ob,
quasi diese Neuregelung der FCC auch tatsächlich auf diese Einigung konkret eine Auswirkung hat, weil dann würde ich sagen, greift es und ansonsten ist da vielleicht unter Umständen noch irgendein Schlupfloch drin, was man bisher nicht sieht.
Aber ähm ja, okay. Einen Punkt hast du, glaube ich, noch, ne?
Ja da also es gab das war in der US-Debatte, das haben wir hier nie so behandelt, weil es ein bisschen detail aus meiner Perspektive war. Äh
es gibt keinen Universaldienstfonds, das war auch mal so eine so eine Idee oder Drohung, äh die die
FCC irgendwie hatte, dass wir sagten, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, wir müssen irgendwie so eine Universal, also eine, wir müssten die Netzbetreiber müssen in einen Fonds einzahlen, der dafür verwendet wird, alle ans Netz anzuschließen über separate Lösungen.
Also mit anderen Worten, sie müssen äh zur Grundversorgung irgendwie beitragen, da das wurde auch gestrichen,
für diese Regulation haben jetzt die drei Demokraten in der FCC gestimmt und die zwei Republikaner in der FCC waren dagegen. Ähm die Meldung ist noch relativ jung. Es gibt erst erste Einschätzungen. Ich bin mal gespannt, was sich da ähm.
Was da jetzt noch an Teufeln aus den Details gezogen wird.
Weil ich meine diese, dieser Kampf um die letzte Meile, der wird ja für meinen Geschmack einfach noch zu wenig geführt so, ne? Also ich ähm das da daran krankt wirklich das System und es mag da viele gute Argumente geben, aber ich,
also auch sagen wir mal dagegen, ja, was für Investitionen et cetera äh betrifft, aber über kurz oder lang wäre es wahrscheinlich einfach das, was ähm uns
viel offeneren Markt geben würde, wenn also jeder in der Lage wäre, dort Dienstleistungen anzubieten und der Zugang zu dieser letzten Meile diskriminierungsfrei wäre, dann ähm
würde sich da mittelfristig sicherlich ein sehr viel ähm blumigeres Internetlandschaftsbild ergeben, als wir das derzeit haben oder was auch derzeit auch nur im Ansatz eine Aussicht steht.
Wir kommen nachher nochmal in im Rahmen einer anderen Meldung zur zuletzten Meile. Vielleicht könnten wir die sogar vornehmen. Ich schaue mal ganz kurz.
Nicht so wirklich. Oder sollen wir das mal machen? Doch, machen wir. Wir wir nehmen jetzt eine wir nehmen eine eine andere Meldung mit herein jetzt. Die nehmen wir vor, weil da geht's auch ein bisschen um die äh um die letzte Meile. Sollen wir das machen, Tim.
Du meinst den Zwangsrater? Genau. Mhm. Machen wir das einfach mal.
Genau, es gibt nämlich, es gibt noch eine noch eine ganz gute Nachricht.
Zwei gute Nachrichten in einer Sendung.
Ja, keine Sorge, es kommen gleich noch schlechte. Es kommen gleich noch schlecht.
Puh.
Ähm äh lass mal gucken. Ja, kaum noch schlechter. Der äh der äh das.
Wirtschaftsministerium.
Wirtschaftsminister.
Wirtschafts ja BMW.
Einen Gesetzesentwurf jetzt endlich fertig, wo sie sagen, wir wollen,
uns gegen die Zwangsrouter wenden. Das ist ein Thema, das haben wir schon öfter behandelt, aber ich wiederhole das nur mal kurz, im Moment definieren die Netzbetreiber den Router, den sie dir geben, als den Netzabschlusspunkt.
Ähm und damit als etwas, was ihnen gehört und was Teil ihrer Infrastruktur ist.
Also nicht alle machen das, aber.
Genau und,
wodurch sie dafür sorgen, dass sie, also sie sagen, wir möchten nicht, dass du einen anderen Router benutzt, als den, den wir dir geben. Und aus diesen Gründen geben wir dir nicht die Daten, die du bräuchtest, um einen anderen Router zu konfigurieren.
Also gutes Beispiel sind sowohl jetzt hier die ganzen ähm Internet über,
Anbieter, aber auch im DSL-Bereich, zum Beispiel Aqua macht das auch sehr gerne, dass sie da nichts rausrücken und dir einfach so eine komische Box hinstellen, die einfach nix kann.
Ja und vor allem und und Löcher hat ohne Ende, also das ist ja echt diese easy easy Boxen heißen die von.
Genau. Ja, easy, easy tot. Würde ich sagen, ne.
Das sind das sind Vollkatastrophen, das sind richtige Vollkatastrophen, diese Dinger. Na ja, okay. Ähm.
Das ist auch schon mal eine interessantes Argument gegen Zwangsrater, ne. Ich meine äh die Betreiber argumentieren mit, ja, wie sollen wir denn da so ein Sicherheits-Updates einspielen, aber so kann man auch sagen, es gibt da irgendwie nicht ausreichend Wettbewerb bei euch
dass ihr euch dadrum kümmert und euch sind dann die Kunden eigentlich am Ende egal und äh ja, ihr seid nicht in der Lage, diese Sicherheitsgarantien auch zu bieten.
Also ganz, ganz klarer Fall äh hinzu kommt, dass ja diese Routerbeschränkung
in der Vergangenheit auch gerne dazu benutzt wurden, um bestimmte Beschränkungen irgendwie durchzusetzen. Ich erinnere mich also, es ist jetzt schon länger her, das gibt's, glaube ich, heutzutage nicht mehr, aber es gab irgendwie bei Alis diesen Fires, der dass das WLAN auf zwei Nutzer beschränkt war oder so was,
dass sie, dass sie quasi Einschränkungen in dein Heimnetz gebracht haben, mehr oder.
Oder das Wort erstmal gar kein WLAN da ist und du dann nochmal extra mag, extra Fleisch, dass das dann irgendwie überhaupt erst freigeschaltet wird, dieses Feature, ne, also das ist sozusagen Dinge, die irgendwie eigentlich ohnehin schon da rumstehen, dann überhaupt erst eingeschaltet werden. Genau.
Okay, Ende vom Lied dagegen waren natürlich die Verbraucherschützer und die Routerhersteller,
Äh und die haben gesagt, der Netzabschlusspunkt ist doch wirklich wohl die Dose, wo das ganze Ding am Ende reingesteckt wird. Und jetzt gibt es einen Entwurf über das Gesetz, über Funkanlagen und Telekommunikationsenteinrichtungen.
Äh von dem ein Referentenentwurf am Mittwoch vorgestellt wurde, dass außerdem eine EU-Richtlinie für Wettbewerb auf dem Markt für Telekommunikationsenteinrichtungen umsetzen soll und,
auch die Vereinbarung des Koalitionsvertrags, denn die Aufhebung des Roter Zwanges stand im Koalitionsvertrag. Ähm.
Und dieses Gesetz soll eben äh.
Im Telekommunikationsgesetz den Zugang als passiven äh Netzabschlusspunkt definieren. Ähm und das heißt im im Ende im Endeffekt, dass die.
Netzbetreiber dazu verpflichtet werden, die notwendigen Infos mitzuliefern, die du benötigst, um einen Router deiner Wahl in Betrieb zu nehmen.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht. Ähm.
Wenn auch, ich meine, ja, das ist halt das ist halt so ein typisches Verbraucherschutzthema, ne? Ist super
spart uns den Ärger, diese dämlichen Easy-Boxen aufzumachen und da die Daten rauskratzen zu müssen,
wobei bei bei ähm bei Vodafone weiß ich gar nicht genau, ob das noch so ein Problem war, dass sie die Daten nicht mehr rausgerückt haben. Im Moment, ich bin da gar nicht so im Bilder, äh welcher.
Ich kenne mindestens einen Anschluss, die sich da noch irgendwie zicken.
Okay, das ist also jetzt vorbei. Ähm.
Na, noch ist es nicht vorbei. Ich meine, das ist ja zunächst einmal nur ein Gesetzesentwurf, ne.
Ja, das stimmt,
Ich bin mal gespannt, es gibt wirklich wenig sinnvolle Argumente dagegen, ne. Insofern habe ich Hoffnung, dass das äh dass man das durchgesetzt bekommt. Ähm.
Dann haben wir,
in diesem Zusammenhang die Meldung, dass die Bundesnetzagentur die Telekom zu fünfundsiebzigtausend Euro Strafe wegen Verschleppung bei Anschlussumzügen verdonnert hat. Das war das, wo ich gerade auch so ein bisschen auf die letzte Meile noch zu sprechen.
Ja. Bei einem einzigen speziellen Anschluss äh Umzug oder generell.
Generell, denn es gab fünftausend offizielle Beschwerden im Jahr zweitausendvierzehn
echt krass ist, oder? Also fünftausend offizielle Beschwerden, die bei der Bundesnetzagentur gelandet sind, wo Leute gesagt haben, ey, ich ziehe von der Telekom weg
bin seit Monaten äh seit Wochen oder Monaten von meiner äh von meinen Telekommunikationsdiensten
schottet. Ähm und ich äh zeige hier eine Verschleppung an. Das ist krass. Ich meine, ich wäre nie auf die, also ich meine,
Selbst wenn du da sechs Wochen in in der Geiselhaft bist, ja, da da wär selbst ich nicht auf die Idee gekommen, meine Beschwerde zu durchdringen zu lassen,
umso krasser ist es, weißt du, wenn also das ist ja nur die Spitze des Eisbergs, das sind die Leute, die am Ende so terrorisiert wurden.
Dass sie sich nicht mehr anders zu helfen wussten als das bei der Bundesnetzagentur zu melden.
Ja.
Ja? Immer, jetzt sagt die ähm da kann man bis zu hunderttausend Euro Strafe verhängen, was net, ich meine, fünfundsiebzigtausend Euro ist ja ein Klacks, ne. Aber.
Ja, ist ein Klacks und das sind fünfzehn Euro pro Beschwerde, also vieles ist jetzt nicht, ne.
Und die die kommen kann sich dafür für die fünfundsiebzigtausend Euro kriegt sie, dass jeder dir sagt äh
Anbieterwechsel, oh, oh, oh, oh, Vorsicht, Vorsicht. Bloß nicht Anbieter wechsel, da bist du sechs Wochen lang in einer Diaspora oder so, ne? Das ist jetzt, also das ist eigentlich relativ günstig für dieses äh für diesen Werbeeffekt.
Ähm aber äh es wurde die die fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro Rabatt zu einhunderttausend Euro Höchststrafe hat die Telekom dafür bekommen, dass sie sich in letzter Zeit wohl aktiv engagiert hätte.
In Richtung ein dafür zu sorgen, dass Besserung eintrete und so,
sprach dann auch der Telekom-Sprecher von einem schwierigen Prozess, der in der Regel aber problemlos äh funktioniere und für den man bald ähm mit einer äh automatisierten Schnittstelle,
eine Lösung hätte. Vielleicht mal vorsichtig,
So, ich meine, diese Telekom ist seit Jahrzehnten organisch gewachsen,
Und das ist äh sicherlich ein sehr uneinheitlicher Haufen. Allein die Dokumentation dieser ganzen Kupferkabel, die die irgendwie rumfliegen haben, ist sicherlich ähm eine eine Herausforderung von epischem Ausmaß und
sicherlich auch nicht von heute auf morgen geleistet. Das würde ich dann zu deren Entschuldigung schon mal,
anbringen und aber gleichzeitig auch anmerken, dass der Effekt nämlich, dass es dann langsamer läuft, natürlich in deren wirtschaftlichen äh Interesse ist und das ist natürlich dann problematisch. Insofern,
ist es sicherlich positiv, dass da jetzt 'ne 'ne Maßnahme ergriffen wurde und wir werden.
Sehen, wie sich das weiter entwickelt, aber fünfundsiebzigtausend ist natürlich auch echt ein Klacks. Also das ist ein das ist ein Business Case, ja. Wenn wenn alle dich dafür davor, wenn alle davor warnen.
Wenn alle deine Kunden davor waren, von dir wegzugehen und alles, was du dafür bezahlen musst, sind einmal fünfundsiebzigtausend, das ist echt äh das ist super,
das würde ich auch machen, anstelle der Telekom. Würde ich, würde ich aufrunden, würde ich sagen, komm, hunderttausend, lass gut sein.
Genau, die fünfundzwanzig, die legen wir einfach noch drauf, kein Problem.
Kommt in die Kaffeekasse, ne? Ihr macht ja einen, ihr macht ja einen guten Job.
Macht euch mal. Macht euch mal einen schönen Tag. Macht mal früher Schluss heute.
Schreibt man schreibt mal eine große Pressemitteilung so damit.
Erzählt die Geschichte. So.
Oh je,
Ja gut, aber grundsätzlich sind das schon mal ganz gute Tendenzen. Ich finde das auch interessant, dass das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium an der Stelle auch wirklich,
Ja, ich meine einerseits so ein bisschen, man könnte sagen eine Position des Verbraucherschutzes einnimmt, ja, man könnte natürlich auch sagen, ähm.
Eine Position der Deregulierung.
Deregulierung oder sagen wir mal auch so Unternehmen wie AVM und ähnlichen Herstellern dann auch äh,
einräumt, dass sie da auch einen Markt brauchen, so ja, der sonst äh sträflich entzogen worden wäre und ich muss sagen, man kann mh,
und jetzt hier groß irgendwie Hersteller äh loben zu wollen, aber es ist durchaus so,
Es gibt halt einfach Hersteller, die bemühen sich einfach noch, in diesem Endgeräte ähm Markt auch wirklich ähm neue Qualitäten und Features zu schaffen
Ja, da passiert richtig was. Ich mag mir gar nicht ausmalen, wie es wäre, wenn diese Boxen wirklich nur noch vom Provider kommen. Das das wäre der der ewige Stillstand.
Ja, vor allem, weil die Provider natürlich äh sich möglichst den wirklich den Schrott.
Irgendwo zusammen kaufen und da wirklich, das ist also kann da jetzt nicht so so
genau ins Detail gehen, aber wir haben uns mal ein paar solcher Kisten angeschaut und ähm da kannst du wirklich ähm die Hände äh überm Kopf zusammenschlagen, was da ähm.
Was da den Leuten ins Wohnzimmer äh gestellt wird, ne. Und diese Geräte sind wirklich in der Regel eine Katastrophe, weil natürlich die die Provider
auch da Geld sparen wollen, ne, für die ist wichtig, dass sie eine schöne Meldung haben, in der drinsteht, ja äh.
Hier, ne, Tauf, da, der, der so und so Box X dreitausend oder so mit mit TurboDSL oder so, natürlich nicht, dass du da wirklich eine vernünftige Kiste nachher zu Hause stehen hast.
Ja und habe auch das Interesse, sagen wir mal, jetzt so besonders gut funktionierende Geräte zu haben, ist ja auch
gar nicht da, weil das werden ja neue Features, dann wollen die Kunden das auch noch haben, dann muss man das auch noch einbauen und so. So kannst du halt immer noch sagen, hier meine neue shiny shiny super äh Bock kann ja irgendwie das, das, das und das. Wieso äh bietet ihr mir das nicht? Auf meiner Seite wäre doch alles in Ordnung.
Ein Trauma.
Drama, ja.
Kommen wir, kommen wir zu den schlechten. Kommen wir zu den schlechten ähm Beispielen. Ich glaube auch ein Gesetzesentwurf aus dem äh Bundeswirtschaftsministerium. Ich bin jetzt gerade verzweifelt am Googlen, wo der überhaupt genau herkommt. Ähm.
Aber ich glaube, wo kommt der her?
Sind wir jetzt bei der Störerhaftung? Genau. Mhm.
Wir erinnern uns an das alte Problem des Provider Privileges ähm was äh heißt, wenn.
Wenn ich mein WLAN aufmache und da jemand reinkommt und der macht dann Mist. Und äh die Tele, die die Telekom, stellt dann nachher fest, das war vom Anschluss von dem Neumann aus. Dann äh bin ich dafür haftbar,
und ein, weil ich quasi als Störer diesen dieser Person Zugang zum Internet verschafft habe und das hätte ich nicht tun dürfen. Ähm,
Provider jedoch sind davon ausgeschlossen, Internet Provider und der eigentliche Gesetzestext, den man heute liest,
lautet ja sogar eigentlich, dass jeder, der irgendjemanden Zugang zum Internet gibt,
davon ausgeschlossen ist, dafür zu haften, die gängige Rechtsprechung ist aber eine andere.
So wie die Zusammenfassung des bei Lokbuchnetz Politik immer wieder eterierten Problemes. Und ähm.
Jetzt hatte uns ja auch der Koalitionsvertrag versprochen, dass man sich des Problemes annehmen würde, nämlich diese Rechtsunsicherheit auflösen, indem man eine klare,
Regelung schafft in diesem Bereich. Und die Hoffnung war natürlich die Abschaffung der Störerhaftung, wir erinnern uns, da gibt's vom digitale Gesellschaft,
vom Verein digitale Gesellschaft sogar ein Gesetzesentwurfsvorschlag, in dem gesagt wird, alles klar, schreibt einfach so das Gesetz dahin, dann sind alle, dann ist die Störerhaftung weg, dann kann jeder ein offenes WLAN anbieten, alles ist gut
ähm da diesem diesen Vorschlag ist die Bundesregierung jetzt nicht gefolgt, sondern hat gesagt, okay für Hotspot Anbieter.
Wollen wir feststellen, dass sie Providern gleichgestellt werden, wenn,
Sie zumutbare Maßnahmen ergreifen, um Missbrauch zu vermeiden.
Als zumutbare Maßnahme sehen sie, dass in der Regel durch Verschlüsselung sichergestellt wird, dass keine unberechtigten Zugriff auf dieses Netz oder diesem Netz Zugang bekommen,
Und der soll also in der ähm,
Resultat dann sowas sein wie eine Anmeldung zusammen mit der Erklärung, dass man keine Rechtsverletzung begehen würde.
Also.
Genau, so so ähm mit,
Im Zweifelsfall namentlicher Registrierung. Und jetzt gibt es einen, gibt es darin einen Paragrafen, der in diesem geliebten Entwurf oder irgendwie veröffentlichten Entwurf noch in Klammern steht, wo man sagt.
Ein Anbieter, der einen Zugang nicht,
anlässlich einer geschäftsmäßigen Tätigkeit oder als eine öffentliche Einrichtung zur Verfügung stellt,
muss den Namen des Nutzers kennen.
Namen oder die Identität.
Die Identität würde ich also Namen kann man ja mit Identität übersetzen. Ich habe das jetzt nur äh eben in den in den ähm in in den Sekundärquellen äh geforscht. Ähm.
Das heißt, das ist der Todesstoß für Freifunk oder das wäre ähm der Todesstoß für Freifunk,
Freifunk sagt ja, zack, offenes Wlan, alles durch irgendeinen VPN gerutet. Ähm das, was am Ende rauskommt, äh ist ein äh beim Ribe eingetragener ISP. Damit ist er von der Störerhaftung befreit und alle sind glücklich.
Ähm und natürlich dann noch äh auf zweiter Ebene die Mesh Netzwerke und so. Also diese ganze tolle Infrastruktur, die Freifunnker äh für uns gebaut haben.
Soll damit im Prinzip in der Form verhindert werden, dieses anonyme, freie, offene Netz für alle,
ohne Anmeldung, ohne alles. Einfach sagen, Infrastruktur brauchst du, bitteschön. Hier hast du im Netz ist wichtig, hol deine E-Mails ab oder was auch immer du machen möchtest, ähm, freies Internet, wir teilen. Ähm, dieser Ansatz,
soll hier also oder würde mit diesem Absatz, der eben jetzt noch in Klammern steht, ähm vollständig,
äh Abgesicht werden,
und natürlich auch in dem, was ich vorher gesprochen habe, wo man sagt, okay, ein Provider äh wird ein Hotspot-Provider wird gleichgestellt, wenn er durch Verschlüsselung äh sicherstellt, dass keine unberechtigten Zugriff bekommen. Das heißt ja auch, da wird ähm.
Explizit Freifunk wieder ausgeklammert, ja? Also es man liest hier die Handschrift, dass sie verhindern wollen, dass Menschen WLANs aufmachen.
Und die einfach teilen. Und dann äh keine keine Störerhaftung äh
nicht mehr in Störerhaftung genommen werden, weil das wäre natürlich ein Ende des Abmahnwesens, wenn äh wenn einfach alle hier WLAN aufmachen, kannst du keinem mehr äh nachweisen.
Dass er äh diese diese rechte Verletzung durchgeführt hat, weil eben jeder sagen kann, ey, das ist hier ein offener Netzpunkt, den ich betreibe, weiß ich doch nicht, wer da drin hing. Ähm was natürlich eigentlich.
Man kann man natürlich sagen, das wäre jetzt schade, da würde ein ein sehr lukrativer Geschäftszweig ähm in unserem Land wegbrechen, der aber bis jetzt irgendwie wenig,
Beitrag geleistet hat, unsere Gesellschaft irgendwie voranzubringen,
freier, vernünftiger Netzzugang für alle, überall, das wäre etwas, was unsere Gesellschaft voranbringt, insofern bin ich da natürlich persönlich auf der äh auf der Position, dass ich das dieses diese Störerhaftungsgeschichte.
Ähm gerne dem natürlich opfern würde.
Ähm mächtigere Lobbyisten sind da anderer Meinung und ähm haben mit diesem, in diesem Gesetzesentwurf echt krass,
ihre Handschrift unterbringen können,
Außerdem wurde angekündigt, dass man sagt, man möchte im Paragraph zehn Telemediengesetz die Haftungsfreistellung für ähm,
Anbieter ähm aufweichen. Also im Moment ist das so, wenn ähm,
Wenn ich einen Dienst wie wie Dropbox oder ähm,
mega Upload oder pasted oder was gibt's noch für Scherze, wenn ich irgendwas betreibe mit Usergenrated Content.
Dann hafte ich nicht dafür, was die Leute dadrauf laden oder was die Leute da eintragen, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass ich darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt werde. Also ähm nehmen wir irgendwie
mein Refi für da, was ich da früher mal betrieben habe. Wenn da jetzt jemand etwas äh bösartiges getan hat, dann,
habe ich nicht dafür gehaftet. Ja, ich habe aber sehr wohl ab dem Moment dafür gehaftet, wenn es mir angezeigt wurde. Also, wenn jetzt ähm.
Wenn jetzt.
Gesagt hat, hier blöde Nazibeleidigungen, was weiß ich, persönliche Beleidigung, sonst irgendwas.
Dann hätte und diese Person hätte dann gesagt, hier ähm Neumann auf deiner Seite äh wird das hier verbreitet. Du bist,
es steht in deiner Macht, das zu löschen, tu das, du bist jetzt darüber in Kenntnis, dann ähm ab dem Moment.
Ich dann in der in der Löschverpflichtung, ja? Weil, oder, oder, muss ich eben sagen, OK, nee,
Nazibeleidigung, die eigne ich mir jetzt an. Ich übernehme die Verantwortung, die weiterhin in die Welt zu setzen. Äh und das ist ja eigentlich eine ganz vernünftige Regelung und das das führt natürlich dazu, dass ähm,
bestimmten Diensten, wo häufig Urheberrechtsverletzendes Material hochgeladen wird. Ähm ein möglichst,
Also ein, ein, ein langer oder ein ausgiebiger, ein Aufgeber,
ein ausgiebiger Prozess des Anzeigens von solchen von von Rechteverletzungen und der darauffolgenden Löschung stattfindet, also so ein Notes und Take-Down-Verfahren, ne, also ähm im Prinzip kann man sagen,
was weiß ich, so ein so ein Rapid Share ähm.
Da wird immer wieder äh illegales Material hochgeladen und dieses illegale Material wird immer wieder angezeigt und die sagen, oh Scheiße, sorry, müssen wir löschen, dann wird der Link gelöscht. Ja?
Und böse Zungen könnten natürlich jetzt behaupten, dass dadurch dass,
Eigentlich nur dafür da ist, genau diesen Dienst anzubieten, nämlich Urheberrechtsverletzendes Material äh in Umlauf zu bringen.
Und deswegen soll jetzt im Paragraph zehn Telemediengesetz die Haftungsfreistellung, die Rapid Share genießt bis zum Zeitpunkt der in Kenntnissetzung für besonders Gefahr geeignete Dienste aufgelöst werden.
Mit anderen Worten, Rapid Share steht da und sagt, ah, wunderbar, hier, irgendwas hochgeladen. Ähm, hm, verbreiten, verbreiten, verbreiten, Oberbeschwerde löschen und handelt im Rahmen des Gesetzes. Ähm.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, ist ein besonders gefahrgeeigneter Dienst, dann könnte also gesagt werden, pass mal auf, bevor du irgendetwas verbreitest, bist du in der Pflicht zu prüfen, ob das nicht andere Leute Rechte verletzt.
Und wenn das andere Leuts Rechte verletzt, dann bist du dafür in Haftung. Das heißt, da würde natürlich ähm relativ schnell einfach zumachen müssen, weil sie das nicht leisten könnten.
Ja gut, ich meine macht jetzt sowieso in einem Monat dicht, von daher ist das äh wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht das Allerbeste. Ja, die haben äh Auflösung zum einunddreißigsten März angekündigt.
Okay, ich äh ich meine.
Solche die.
Musste das jetzt erwähnen, weil sonst sind die Kommentare wieder voll damit. Ja, wir haben zu Kenntnis genommen, das eh nicht mehr lange da ist, aber äh Fall äh Uploader hier, ne. Ich äh.
Und aber ich will noch ganz kurz an der Stelle loswerden. Solche Pfeil-Upload-Services nutzen ist eben eh schlechter Stil
Ja, also das ist äh ob das jetzt mega oder Rappet, oder wie die alle heißen, das ist einfach schlechter Stil, ja? Ich meine, die machen die haben ja tatsächlich ein Geschäftsmodell dahinter, nämlich, dass sie eben diese äh diese Volumenbeschränkungen haben und sagen, okay
gib äh zehn.
Ergibt zehn Euro im Monat, dann kannst äh schneller und mehr runterladen oder so. Ähm und das heißt, dass sie natürlich da abzielen auf große Dateien und große Dateien sind eben äh Videos und
wir erinnern uns an diese Probleme, die es dabei Kino TO gab und bei dass da eben
bandenmäßiger Urheberrechtsverletzungen,
äh Betrieb dahinter hing, um irgendwann am Ende mit so einem Halbliga mit einem legalen Geschäftsmodell am Ende Geld äh zu verdienen, ähm aber auf,
illegalem Wege dieses Geschäftsmodell besonders attraktiv zu machen.
Ähm das sind jetzt echt nicht die die Freiheitskämpfer, mit denen du dich assoziieren möchtest. So. Gleichzeitig ist aber natürlich, wenn du, wenn du.
Wenn du das jetzt umkehrst, ich meine es gibt immer es gibt immer Freiheiten in dieser Welt, äh die Menschen,
ausnutzen. Und auch zum zum großen Maße und da müssen wir uns als Gesellschaft fragen, wollen wir, weil diese Freiheit von einem,
Anteil der Menschen ausgenutzt wird, wollen wir uns als Gesellschaft von dieser Freiheit verabschieden. Und da muss man sich eben überlegen, wenn wir das tun, welcher Schaden entsteht dann für uns als Gesellschaft? Und wenn du jetzt sagst, jeder, der irgendwie was im Internet einen Dienst anbietet,
ähm wo Nutzerinhalte einstellen können, haftet dafür plötzlich, dann kannst du dir vorstellen, was dann los ist, das kann man sich dann einfach,
irgendwann nicht mehr leisten. Dann kannst du dir nicht mehr leisten einen Blog mit Kommentarspalte zu haben, weil du Angst haben musst, dass irgendein Spacken da einen Link zu irgendeinem Material oder was auch immer und du auf einmal dafür haftest.
Das heißt, am Ende wäre, wenn man dieses, wenn man dieses, ähm, diese Haftungsfreistellung auflöst, wäre das Ergebnis,
so eine Art Vorauseilender Gehorsam.
Der Dienste, Anbieter und auch der kleineren äh Firmen und damit so eine Komplettauflösung irgendwie ähm.
Von Dienste an Dienstleistern, die irgendwie halt auch die die Gesellschaft voranbringen und einen freien Austausch ermöglichen.
Ja, es ist alles auch irgendwie extrem schlechter Stil. Also allein der Gedanke, dass diese ganzen Kepte
Portals, die eigentlich mich schon so schon am ersten Tag, als sie in mein Leben kam,
dermaßen aufgeregt und ärgerlich gemacht haben, dass die jetzt irgendwie gegebenenfalls sogar noch gesetzlich festgeschrieben werden, also denn diesen Gedanken kann ich mich überhaupt nicht gewöhnen,
die ganze Zeit, was das so für Konsequenzen hat, für die Bereitstellung von WLAN auf Konferenzen zum Beispiel, ja, so Kongress, meine, man kann natürlich jetzt hier geschäftsmäßige Tätigkeit, also im Falle des äh Kongresses kann man das vielleicht sogar noch
äh ne
Also könnte man das sozusagen noch äh als Argument herausziehen, aber da gibt's sicherlich genug Grenzbereiche, wo jetzt äh irgendwelche Veranstaltungen halt einfach mal ein WLAN aufmachen
wo jetzt nur ein Verein dahinter steht, dem keine
geschäftsmäßige Tätigkeit nachgesagt werden kann oder diese nicht für sich in Anspruch nehmen kann, um dieser Regelung zu entfliehen und das ist irgendwie alles ganz wild.
Also das, das, das ist das Ziel ist hier ganz klar. Es geht immer darum, dass die sowohl die Bundesregierung als auch diese Rechte Verwerterlobby, die wollen, dass einfach niemand im Internet mehr,
identifizierbar ist. So, sie wollen im Prinzip, ne, das sagen sie auch immer so, ähm äh,
hier Ausweispflicht oder sowas, ne? Es kommt ja immer wieder hoch. Und wenn der nächste,
Jetzt wird gerade wieder das tolle das tolle Thema behandelt. Äh das kann ja nicht sein, dass irgendjemand anonym irgendeinen Stuff über irgendjemand anderem im Internet,
Seite fünf in der Kommentarspalte behauptet. Das wird immer wieder hochgerollt und es geht immer wieder darum, diese Anonymität im Internet abzu ähm.
Abzuschaffen. Und das Krasse ist, du siehst halt hier an in diesem ähm in diesem Bereich ähm,
die Zukunftsvision der Regierung. Kannst du sehr genau da ablesen. Nämlich, erstens, alle sollen keine Anonymität im Netz,
und und diejenigen, die frei und gratis und ehrenamtlich Infrastruktur für alle Leute, die sich in der Bundesrepublik befinden, unentgeltlich bereitstellen, ja? Die bekommen auf die Fresse,
Die bekommen auf die Fresse, weil sie andere daran hindern, Geld zu verdienen. Und das ist echt ähm,
Also da das siehst du an nichts schöner als an diesem Gesetzesentwurf, ja? Also wirklich diese Gesellschaft einfach mal voranzubringen, ähm infrastrukturfrei zur Verfügung zu stellen, auf das,
alle davon partizipieren, auf das Mehrwert geschaffen werde, ja? Das soll äh verhindert werden. Es geht denen darum, irgendwie
Hotspotbetreiber, das ist eine Dienstleistung, da kann man Geld verdienen, das ist Infrastruktur, die wird jetzt hier von Kabel Deutschland, weiß der Geier ausgerollt und dafür muss Geld verlangt werden. Und wer wer da irgendwie aus Idealismus ehrenamtlich dieses Geschäftsmodell kaputtmacht, den
den Kloppen war kaputt. Und das ist ähm das ist natürlich bedauerlich. Das ist sehr bedauerlich.
Ist die Frage, was ich äh jetzt noch dagegen tun.
Na ja, da da also gegen diesen Gesetzesentwurf, da müssen wir halt irgendwie drauf kloppen, ne? Hilft jetzt nix. Da müssen halt jetzt irgendwie müssen wir unsere Lobbyanstrengungen.
Verstärken und dafür sorgen,
dass das eben nicht durchkommt in der Form, weil das eben, das ist ja so ein Rückschritt wieder, ne, ist das einfach nur Rückschritt in äh in in die schlechte Zeit.
Dunkle Zeiten.
Naja, ich habe noch eine kleine Meldung. Die fand ich ganz lustig und weil weil ich ja immer wieder noch auf diese Demeld Sache angesprochen werde, habe ich mir gedacht, dass das ähm erzähle ich jetzt mal an der.
Das ist doch gar nicht so ein großer Erfolg geworden, wie alle gedacht haben, oder?
Nee, ist gar nicht so ein großer Erfolg geworden. Ähm äh es.
Ein Wunder.
Es gab jetzt eine Unterrichtung durch die Bundesregierung.
Und die Bundesregierung hat dann eben einen äh einen Zwischenbericht abgegeben, äh zu dem sie verpflichtet ist, im Rahmen des D-Mailgesetzes, wo eben drin steht, die Bundesregierung unterrichtet regelmäßig über den Fortschritt bei dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Und ähm in diesem, es gibt bis jetzt circa eine Millionen identifizierter Privatanwender,
und eine hohe fünfstellige Zahl von identifizierten Organisationen, die einen D Mail äh.
Account haben, nicht benutzen haben.
Benutzen haben, ja? Ähm Deutschland hat achtzig Millionen Einwohner ungefähr, ne? Das heißt, du bist irgendwie bei etwas über einem Prozent der Bevölkerung, die du bis jetzt durchdrungen hast. Und das.
Finde ich aber schon ganz schön viel.
Also Konstanz halt irgendwie da kreide ich mal einen Fehler. Ein Konstanz hat auf Netzpolitik org geschrieben, es werden irgendwie zehn Prozent, was nicht stimmt. Wir haben leider viel mehr Deutsche als wir, als uns vielleicht lieb sein mag. Aber ähm,
die die ähm äh,
Ich meine, wenn du mal überlegst, was die sich angestrengt haben, ja, ich meine, du konntest irgendwie, was haste nicht alles bekommen für einen D-Mail-Anschluss? Hier
Schuhgutschein von Zalando. Inzwischen sind die bei der Lufthansa auf fuffzehntausend Meilen hoch. Das mache ich fast
also für fünfzehntausend Meilen war, bin ich schon echt, dafür kannst du irgendwie einmal gratis nach oder nicht gratis, aber da hat er mit fünfzehntausend Meilen kannst du schon was machen. Ähm,
die hauen dir da wirklich die den Zucker äh mit dazu, ja? Und versuchen alles, um dieses Ding irgendwie äh zu zu Verbreitung zu bringen.
Und es gelingt ihnen nicht. Ähm ich wurde da von dem ähm Rudi Weiß, Rüdiger Weiß, Professor Rüdiger Weiß, ähm,
Gründungsmitglied, digitale Gesellschaft, ähm altes Haus im CCC. Ähm.
Letztens auch gelobt, dass ich mir diesen Erfolg auch ein bisschen äh dass ich zu diesem Erfolg, zu diesem Misserfolg durchaus auch beigetragen hätte
gelobt. Das war, da habe ich mich drüber gefreut. Ähm ich glaube aber, dass das das Ding halt auch so äh sowas von so dämlich genug ist, dass es halt auch ohne mein Zutun ein Rohrkrepierer ist. Aber natürlich freue ich mich,
dass ich auch dazu einen bescheidenen Beitrag leisten konnte. Aber jetzt pass mal auf.
Teile ich die Einschätzung, aber also beide Einschätzungen teile ich.
Das Schöne ist richtig geil. So, jetzt haben sie ihren Rohrkrepierer, da kriegen den nicht zu Verbreitungen und dann wird halt gesagt, ja und ähm.
Die Verzögerung, es gab auf Bundesebene Verzögerung durch ein Nachprüfungsverfahren eines Wettbewerbers
Bei der Ausschreibung eines D-Mail-Anbieters für die Bundesverwaltung. Das heißt also, die,
die Bundesregierung hat ausgeschrieben wir brauchen ein Dienstleister, wir müssen ein Demail-Dienstleister für die Bundesverwaltung haben der muss folgendes können.
Ähm und dann musste sowas ja irgendwie Deutschland oder EU weit ausschreiben äh und dann dann können alle darauf pitchen und dann geht die, geht die Bundesregierung hin, vergleicht die Angebote und entscheidet sich für einen Dienstleister und der macht das dann.
So und jetzt ist das passiert und dann hat eben ein,
Ein Wettbewerber, der den Zuschlag nicht bekommen hat, ein Nachprüfungsverfahren angestrengt und das heißt, die Bundesregierung, die Bundesverwaltung, äh die Bundesregierung verklagt, dass sie bei der Vergabe dieses Auftrages nicht
ähm sauber vorgegangen sei. Und dadurch musste dann, hat sich die Bundesregierung dann vom äh vom Oberlandesgericht Düsseldorf wiedergefunden
und musste irgendwie erstmal einen Rechtsstreit über die Vergabe dieses Auftrages gewinnen, was letztendlich zu einer Verzögerung bei der beim Ausrollen dieses dieses D-Mails auf der Verwaltungsebene
äh geführt hat. Und da kann ich nur sagen, sowas kommt davon, wenn man so eine Wirtschaftsförderungsmaßnahme ergreift, zu Recht,
Zu Recht sind die da verklagt worden,
leider natürlich zu Unrecht, wie das Oberlandesgericht Düsseldorf am Ende entschieden hat, aber natürlich passiert dir genau sowas. Wenn du da irgendwelche obskuren Standards definierst, die ein sehr eingeschränkten Nutzerkreis haben, aber eine große.
Ähm eine große Wirtschaftsförderung für die Anbieter bedeuten,
die diesen Dienst dann implementieren, weil letztendlich Wunder halt ein paar Millionen in die Hand genommen, um diesen Demeildiensteanbieter zu bauen. Es war klar, dass den am Ende keine Sau nutzen wird,
Ja, also ich meine, das war jetzt der Dienstanbieter für die Verwaltung. Das heißt, da musste jetzt erstmal dafür gesorgt werden, dass die Verwaltung eben diese E-Mail, D-Mails überhaupt
bekommen kann, ja? Und da wird das ist ja ein riesiges Ding, da kann das ist ja ein Millionenauftrag, ne? Und da setzt du halt ein paar Drittklassige, Programmierer dran oder vielleicht auch ein paar gute Programmierer, um diesen ganzen Scheiß zu implementieren und das ist halt ein dicker Auftrag, das über Jahre lang,
über Jahre ausgesorgt, weil es ja Jahre dauert den ganzen Scheiß zu bauen. Und ähm.
Wäre das jetzt halt irgendwie was vernünftiges gewesen, dann hätten halt wäre es halt günstiger gewesen und und es hätten mehr darauf pitchen können, ne? Und,
Ich meine, wie gesagt, wenn du wenn du Wirtschaftsförderung betreibst, wenn du klare Gesetze machst, dein Ziel es ist, in Deutschland Anbieter zu schaffen, die damit Geld verdienen, dann
musst du dich nicht wundern, wenn du im im Vergabeverfahren auf einmal Querulanten hast, wenn er den Zustand nicht bekommt. Sowas kommt von sowas.
Vor allem wäre es sehr viel sinnvoller gewesen, diese ganzen DE, Mail Mumpels einfach von vorne rein sein zu lassen und das ist einfach äh konsequent auf den existierenden und auch genutzten Internetdiensten aufbauen zu lassen, einfach,
Projekte zu fördern, die es schon gibt, Standards zu fördern, die es schon gibt, sich auch vielleicht mal da einzubringen und vielleicht mal ein bisschen auch eigenes Know-How aufzubauen auf Bundesebene,
Das ist alles etwas, was einfach sträflich unterlassen wird und was vor allem jetzt nach diesem ganzen DE-Mail, Desaster, was ich ich weiß nicht, wie du das gesehen hast, aber als ich das erste Mal von die E-Mail gehört habe, dachte ich mir nur so.
Glaubt doch wohl nicht im Ernst, dass sie als Bundesregierung im Internet einen Standard durchsetzen könnt. Ja, also äh.
Ja vor allem, vor allem, dass, also der Witz.
Der Gedanke allein schon, das ist wirklich absurd.
Der Witz ist ja demel in seiner jetzigen Form, ist eigentlich nur wie mache ich E-Mail,
mit allen Best Practices. Es ist nicht darüber hinaus gedacht, es ist einfach nur so, was wie kann ich den besten E-Mail-Anbieter schaffen,
Aber nicht, wie kann ich über das, was jetzt schon die Besten der Anbieter machen, hinausgehen und irgendwie etwas Sichereres
machen, als das, was es jetzt schon gibt. Das heißt, sie nehmen im Prinzip einen Status quo, da wird nichts drin definiert, was es nicht schon irgendwo auf der Welt gegeben hätte und trotzdem gehen sie hin und sagen, jetzt gehen wir noch bewusst hin, obwohl wir nur den
die Best Practices umsetzen
und machen das nochmal bewusst inkompatibel, damit es nämlich ein lukratives Geschäftsmodell für die Anbieter wird. Und das ist halt ein totaler, also das ist ein totaler Scheiß so. Und jetzt fällt ihnen das nämlich auch genau auf die Füße. Wunderbar, jetzt ist es nämlich richtig geil
Jetzt kommt nämlich bald die EIDAS VO, die.
Die EU Verordnung für elektronische Identifizierung und Vertrauensdienste für elektronische Transaktionen im Binnenmarkt,
Und jetzt pass auf, jetzt kommt jetzt kommt köstlich, es ist so schön, dass ich das nicht schon viel früher vorhergesehen habe, ja.
Die die Bundesregierung geht hin und sagt, wir machen jetzt mal hier Demel. Ja? Wir nennen das Demeil, wir machen das bewusst, inkompatibel und wir machen da irgendeinen obskuren Scheiß.
Und das ist dann am Ende für die für den Gerichtsverkehr mit äh mit der für den für den rechtssicheren Verkehr mit der Verwaltung und den Gerichten,
dann denken sie das Ding nicht zu Ende und machen das ganze Ding kaputt und müssen dann in der Folge, darüber habe ich ja lange genug erzählt in meinem Vortrag da, müssen dann das bestehende Sicherheitsniveau.
Absenken, also das Bestehende verlangte Sicherheitsniveau für Kommunikation.
Also wie ich das äh nicht das technisch implementierte Sicherheitsniveau, sondern die Anforderungen an das Sicherheits.
Forderung an das Sicherheits
wo, damit man kritische Daten darüber übertragen darf, müssen sie absenken. Das heißt, wir haben unsre, wir haben uns einen schlechten Standard geschrieben und mussten dann unsere Gesetze umschreiben, damit sie diesen schlechten Standard überhaupt zulassen, wie lächerlich ist das denn überhaupt
Jetzt haben sie das Ding, ja und jetzt kommt eben die EU-Verordnung über die Harmonisierung des Binnenmarktes.
Wo gesagt wird, na ja ähm und das ist ja klar, diese EU äh Anforderungen sind ja immer das Gleiche, sagen naja der Binnenmarkt muss harmonisiert werden, das geht nicht, dass Deutschland da irgendwie so ein allein Alleingang implementiert,
deshalb äh muss D May dieses gesamte D-Mail-Verfahren jetzt.
In Anbetracht der kommenden elektronischen Identifizierung von Vertrauensdienste, für elektronische Transaktionen im Binnenmarktverordnung der EU muss dem entweder dafür sorgen, dass sie im Rahmen dieser,
Verordnung zum Standard werden.
Oder dass sie mit dieser Verordnung, wie auch immer sie lauten mag, interoperativ werden. Und wenn das nicht, wenn ihnen das, wenn ihnen nicht eins von beiden gelingt, dann hast du demnächst irgendeine EU-Klage,
D Mail, weil D Mail nicht mit der EIDASVO ähm interoperabel ist.
Habe ich das klar ausgedrückt? Ich meine, ich also mit anderen Worten,
Es gibt bald eine EU Verordnung und wenn D-Mail dieser EU Verordnung nicht entspricht, dann muss Demel geändert werden, auf das ist dieser EU-Verordnung entspreche,
und oder es muss jetzt dafür sorgen, dass die EU Verordnung so angepasst wird, dass sie dem entspricht.
Und das heißt, entweder macht die Verordnung D-Mail kaputt oder diese D-Mail-Scheiße macht uns jetzt auch noch die EU Verordnung kaputt,
nachdem sie uns irgendwie die die ähm Gesetze irgendwie äh Strafprozessordnung und was nicht alles für Gesetze kaputt gemacht hat und da das Sicherheitsniveau abgesenkt hat. Denn das, was geschehen ist, ich wiederhole das.
Schön und gut, aber das Schlimme ist, der der Flurschaden bei den Gesetzen, die wir hatten, die nämlich jetzt im Sicherheitsniveau abgesenkt wurden. Im Jahre zweitausenddreizehn oder vierzehn, ja.
Also, das wird entweder wird D-Mail, ich hoffe natürlich, dass D-Mail irgendwann von der EU weggeklagt wird. Ähm auf oder also,
platt gemacht wird durch eine Verordnung, der es dann eben nicht mehr entspricht. Und dann gibt's da eben diese Verfahren oder so, ne,
ja und die die schlechtere Lösung wäre eben, dass jetzt diese EU Verordnung kaputt aufgeweicht wird durch D Mail und dann wäre also der Flurschaden durch D-Mail hätte dann eben nicht mehr nur ein ein nationales Niveau,
sondern ein internationales Niveau, weil wir dann durch eine EU Verordnung den Schaden, durch D-Mail in alle anderen Länder exportieren würden. Also das ist eine Katastrophe von biblischem Ausmaß.
Na ja und außerdem sagen außerdem drohen sie an in diesem Zwischenbericht, dass sie jetzt durch die im Rahmen der digitalen Agenda.
Die flächendeckende Einführung der Demer beschleunigen wollen,
indem sie eine gemeinsame Einarbeitsgruppe mit der Wirtschaft einrichten wollen, in der Erfahrung ausgetauscht und identifizierte Hürden zeitnah adressiert werden.
Diese Arbeitsgruppe hat ihre Arbeit mittlerweile aufgenommen. Das heißt, da wird jetzt von den Abendschweinen aus der Wirtschaft, die auf dieses tote Pferd gesetzt haben, noch irgendwie ressourcen verbrannt und von unserer schönen Regierung, die echt Probleme hat, die sie lösen muss,
Ressourcen verbrannt im Rahmen einer Arbeitsgruppe. Ja, hast du nicht diesen schönen Spruch über Arbeitsgruppen?
Wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß, gründet man einen Arbeitskreis.
Unglaublich und das ist halt das also man sieht hier,
Ein wunderschönes Beispiel für den Fall, too much investit to quid, ja? Du kannst, du hast zu viel investiert in dieses tote Pferd, um es jetzt einfach in der Wüste liegen zu lassen. Sondern du musst.
Dabei ich meine, uns ist doch klar, da wird das dieses Pferd wird da sowieso enden. Also ich meine, es kann mir keine Zukunft vorstellen, in in der ist die E-Mail gibt.
Einfach es wird einfach nicht stattfinden. Ich meine, sie können jetzt gerne noch beschließen, noch weitere
Jahre darauf zu bestehen, dass das ja eigentlich eine gute Idee war und man das ja jetzt nicht sein lassen könnte und überhaupt nur, man müsste ja nur noch mal einen weiteren Arbeitskreis gründen, noch mal drüber reden.
Zu
Aber es wird einfach am Ende äh verändern, ja, weil diese Wüste endet nicht, ja? Kannst du noch so viel äh
versuchen dieses Kamel irgendwie durch die Füße zu treiben, ist das wird einfach wird einfach, das ist einfach eine Fata Morgana, der hier.
Also dieses Kamel ist tot, aber es kriegt jetzt halt so ein Staatsbegräbnis in purem Gold. Und es wird.
Genau.
Wer was ist echt fürchterlich, also diese dieser Dilettantismus, ja und wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt, es ist ja nicht so,
Also stell dir mal vor, welche wenn man jetzt mit dem ganzen Geld, was da jetzt schon verbrannt wurde
einen schönen Weg gegangen wäre, ne, dann hätte man so einen richtig geilen Standard geschrieben, da hätte man vielleicht noch dafür sorgen können, dass die Smartcard-Hersteller,
Naja,
dass man halt irgendwie einen richtig geilen, vernünftigen Sicherheitsstandard umsetzt, den irgendwie auf EU-Ebene exportiert und zu so einem richtigen Wettkampf, der der Implementierer und der Open Sourcecoder und so weiter ähm.
Ja, ich glaube, das, das ist das ist auch schon irgendwie das, was sie auch gerne wollen, ne? Nur, dass sie sich das ähm so ein bisschen so vorstellen wie Früheier, ja. Man macht das Ganze so auf so einer nationalen Ebene und ignoriert einfach den Rest und dann wird das schon irgendwie klappen, wenn da mal nur genug äh Kohle reingepumpt wird. Und.
Also ich muss sagen, deren Interesse ist schon immer dafür zu sorgen, dass wenn sie irgendwelchen Sicherheitskram machen, dass
die äh die deutsche Wirtschaft davon profitiert und dann kommt eben genau sowas raus, wo man irgendwie fünfhundert Seiten Implementierungsregeln schreibt, die da einfach mal dafür sorgen, dass es auf weiter Flur
keine Konkurrenten gibt, weil wer auch immer damit konkurrieren möchte, erstmal irgendwie ein paar Millionen aus der Tasche holen muss, um diesen verrück
Anforderungen allen gerecht zu werden, um
irgendwann vom BSI zertifiziert zu werden. Ja und das ist das ist eine letztendlich eine Markteintrittsbarriere, die da entsteht und das ist einfach nur
ganz klare Wirtschaftsförderung. Und das siehst du natürlich auch bei dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, dass da natürlich die bestehenden Platz
Platzhirsche sagen. Okay, ihr könnt da was machen, aber.
Bitte vergesst nicht, am Ende muss da für uns ein Geschäftsmodell stehen. Und ähm das ist.
Das ist halt immer das Gleiche. Und wenn du dich einmal auf diesen Mist einlässt, dann weißt du, wo du am Ende landest, ja? Und nämlich bei sowas, dass dass du am Ende von einer EU-Verordnung
platt gemacht, wie es Millionen verbrannt hast und und irgendwie äh fuffzehntausend Lufthansa Meilen irgendwie auf jeden Kunden werfen muss. Äh,
den du irgendwie, den du da hintreiben musst, mit so einem Elektroschocker, dass der wenigstens diesen Dienst äh,
dass der wenigstens dieses scheiß Dienst einmal sich da anmeldet und am Ende keine einzige D-Mail verschickt, das ist alles, ne.
Doch erzählt oder? Als der,
Wie war das denn, als da kam noch irgendwie Morgenmagazin oder so was, war hier als D Mail Dresden. Nee, Dresden wurde DMEL City. Und dann saß hier so dieser Kameramann
oder war das der Tonmann? Auf jeden Fall, als ich das alles erzählte, dann dann unterbrach der quasi den Dreh und sagte irgendwie so, boah wat,
weil der weil der irgendwie am Tag vorher so ein Ding abgeschlossen hatte, weil er sagte, na ja, so ein Amazon-Gutschein für, weiß ich nicht, wie viel
viel das inzwischen war, wie hoch die inzwischen im Kurs standen, den lasse ich mir ja nicht entgehen, der wurde Kreideblech na ja, okay, wir reden schon wieder viel zu lange von äh du sagst, das ist, du sagst richtig, es ist ein totes Pferd und
Deswegen rede ich eigentlich auch nicht mehr so gerne darüber, weil mir das ja auch ein bisschen peinlich ist, ne. Das das, dass ich da immer wieder auf dieses immer sagen muss, ja, siehet her,
Das ist ein totes Pferd. Hört auf, es zu reiten. Ja und irgendwann, na ja.
Hören wir jetzt auch mal auf das äh Pferd zu reiten, was was meinst du und kommen mir vielleicht mal langsam so zum Ausklang äh der Sendung. Da gibt's ja auch noch ein paar ganz gute Nachrichten.
Ja genau, es gibt es gibt so eine es gibt eine sehr schöne Kurzmeldung noch zum Abschluss. Ähm nämlich dass der Film Citizen Four einen Oskar gewonnen hat als beste äh Dokumentation. Das ist etwas, was ich ähm.
Erstaunlich finde, weil das natürlich eine ähm,
politische Message der Academy ist, die hier geäußert wird. Ähm das ist doch äh ist doch sehr schön und natürlich auch sehr ähm,
Das ist natürlich eine späte Veredelung auch der der Arbeit von die sich ja immer im im im.
Dienste der Sache persönlich in den Hintergrund gestellt hat, ja? Laurer war nie irgendwie so eine Dampf äh Plaudererin, die sie irgendwie in erster Reihe da äh mit diesen Snow-Dokumenten hausieren gegangen ist,
äh würde ich das übrigens auch nicht unterstellen. Ähm aber sie hat nämlich eine sie hat da ordentliche Arbeit geleistet im Hintergrund und hat dann irgendwann sehr spät und,
ihren Film rausgebracht, der dann eben sehr gut war und der nur in wenigen Kinos am Ende dann gezeigt wurde und,
in dem dann eben porträtiert wurde, eben auch dieser persönliche Teil. Und ja, am Ende hat sie eben,
noch die diese höchste Anerkennung bekommen, die einen Filmemacher bekommen kann. Und das ist natürlich eine das ist natürlich toll,
Großartig, freue ich mich wirklich drüber. Ähm,
gleichzeitig hat sie dann auch noch irgendwie eine Strafanzeige bekommen, weil irgend so ein Ex-Merin meint, da würden jetzt Staatsgeheimnisse in dem Film verraten, herzlichen Dank, vielleicht wird das nochmal zu dem, zu einem größeren kommerziellen Erfolg äh dieses Filmes beitragen.
Na ja, vorher hat's erstmal dazu beigetragen, dass dieser Film äh kostenlos zum Download im Internet äh verfügbar war.
Wie denn jetzt genau? Ist das von ihr ausgegangen? Also ich habe ähm ich weiß, dass John Jan den schon vor ein paar Monaten auf geladen hat.
Ach so und vor ein paar Monaten schon. Ich da.
Oder vor ein paar war das vor ein paar Wochen.
Ich habe das ähm ich muss zugeben, ich bin gerade generell schlecht informiert, weil dieser ganze Umzug äh mich hier noch sehr unter Strom hält, aber ähm Tatsache ist, dieser Film äh liegt im Internet äh vor auf Crypto Punkt äh org, was auch
als das so ein bisschen rumging, dafür gesorgt hat, dass Kultur mal schlecht zu erreichen war,
das passiert eigentlich selten. Und ähm wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, gab es eben ähm eine
gerichtliche Anordnung, dass dieser Film als offizielles Beweismaterial
aufgenommen wird im Rahmen dieser Verhandlung und äh es gibt halt mittlerweile diese Gesetzeslage, dass das alles, was sozusagen, zumindest in dieser Art von.
Klage, die da jetzt waren, die ich jetzt grad nicht benennen kann, ähm muss das alles auch digital öffentlich vorgehalten werden und das gilt dann in dem Fall halt auch für diesen Film,
mit dem Ergebnis, dass dieser Film irgendwie im Netz ist.
Okay, ich, also sorry, das habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht verfolgt. Ähm kann ich nicht kann ich nicht genau was zu sagen. Ich habe erst gedacht, was ist der John für einen Arsch, dass er das äh hochlädt, weil das natürlich äh unter Umständen mit den,
legitimen, finanziellen Interessen von Laura Pointers kollidiert.
Na, ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendeine Änderung
Ich meine, dass das wird äh eher dem entgegenteiligen äh Effekt haben, weil ich meine, die Nerds, die sich das irgendwie ziehen und anschauen, weißt du, es trete ja nur dazu bei, dass dieser Film noch
bekannter wird. Ich meine, jetzt hat er auch noch einen Oscar. Also ich denke nicht, dass der irgendein Mangel an an Einnahmen ähm.
Ich denke auch nicht, dass das irgendwie äh oder ich ich hoffe, dass wir in einer Welt leben, in der Laura Portras äh bis ans Ende ihres Lebens nicht mehr um ihre Existenz fürchten muss. Und ich weiß, dass hier auch sehr äh
sehr liberal mit ihren äh Rechten an diesem Film umgeht, zum Beispiel eine öffentliche, kostenlose Vorführung mit
anschließender oder vorangehender Fragerunde beim einunddreißig C3 veranstaltet hat und
wenn ich mich recht entsinne, haben wir auch mal eine öffentliche Vorführung im äh CCCB äh gehabt,
Äh da ist sie sicherlich Idealistin, die jetzt nicht äh traurig ist, dass dass ihr Geld entgeht, ne.
Das kann man, kann man teilen, ja.
Ich persönlich muss sagen, ich hab's ja diese Woche bis heute nicht gesehen. Ich habe mir gedacht, ich spare mir das auf bis zum einunddreißig C drei und dann da bin ich natürlich nicht reingekommen, weil äh Saal voll,
und ähm.
Soll ich dir was sagen? Ich habe ihn auch noch nicht gesehen, aber ich habe ihn schon runtergeladen.
Seit längerer Zeit hier,
auf. Äh als nächstes gucken, aber diese Zeiten, wo ich auf irgendwie Filme gucke, sind.
Ja, ja, dünn gesät. Äh weißt du was? Wir schauen uns den einfach beide mal in dieser Woche an und dann können wir uns das nächste Mal unterhalten.
Ich, ja ich, ich, ich, ich versuch's, ich versuch's. Ich bin nächste Woche wieder unterwegs, aber.
Es ist sowieso auf dieser nächster illegaler Download, der ja geguckt werden muss, Liste und.
Na dann. Na dann, bleibt uns eigentlich nur noch tschüs sagen.
Wir müssen wir müssen äh danke und tschüss sagen. Ich danke ganz herzlich äh am Ende dieser Sendung, dem Clemens und der Tanja. Und ähm natürlich auch dir lieber Tim.
Für deine für dein Engagement in diesem in diesem Bereich hier.
Ja, ich äh muss dir auch danken, Linos, uns heute alle lieb.
Ich habe mir, ich habe mir ja schon indirekt hier gedankt, indem ich das Lob von von Rüdi äh weitergegeben habe. Das Ding ist Rüdiger Weiß äh lobt einfach nicht. Es ist also so ein so ein in der Matrix, dass er halt da ein Lob ausgesprochen hat.
Finster? Ach.
Doch der lobt schon, aber es er lobt spärlich und äh umso bedeutsamer ist das.
Okay, hat dich stolz gemacht. Na schön. Linus, das war's.
Tim, ich danke dir und wir hören uns nächste Woche. Ciao, ciao.
Genau, bis dann.